twelfth game of the season for tony
godzilla his second one off of the
injured list in st louis on thursday
three hits and two walks but he gave up
just one run and it's kind of been the
story all year four more when he's been
on the mound there's been traffic but
still just 279 era
bouncing ball to trey turner and a
ground out to open the night one down in
the battle will be could tell marta
strike three good morning good afternoon
and good night to the national league's
leading hitter can tell martay
two up two down in this first inning
here's dalton varshall
hello pitches 11 of them strikes luke
tonight making his third start since a
right shoulder strain that forced him to
miss nearly four months this year yeah
one really good start against san diego
six innings gave up one run on four hits
and he pitched well against texas five
innings gave up three runs on four hits
one going for muncie dodgers have seen
uh quite a bit of luke weaver through
the years using pujols is back they did
the trick for justin turner homer twice
with one of his bats the last couple of
days
this is a ladder that is misread by
smith
and a gift of a double for max muncie
thunderman's scoring position for trey
turner on a one-two turner
smacks it by the back down the line past
the diving beer to open the scoring
muncie is in turn it is second back to
back doubles and it's one nothing
and they're looking at seth beer who's
still down on the field
really landed hard on that left rib cage
not sure if that's uh the injury that
they're attending to right now maybe the
shoulder he's coming out so to be up to
will smith to add on here in the first
inning
fastball at 96 is hit out to right ramos
saw the warning track has room and he's
there and luke weaver strands too a long
first it's one nothing element
one two from godzilla
got him swinging and he's retired the
first four
greenero via the strikeout david smith
batting 267. climb drive to center for
bellinger two away in the second two
gone second inning here's josh van meter
on an old one from godzilla
lifts a curveball in the air to center
field bellinger running back on it at
the track with room
six up in six down for tony gonzalez
lead off walk for ramos and the first
base runner for arizona ramos walks to
start the ending and now 2-2 to jake
mccarthy
got him with a breaking pitch
not necessarily where he wanted but he
gets away with it and gets his 4th k
definitely his fourth pitch and the
slider when it has surpassed the split
finger change you have to remember that
the slider was in development when he
got here two out for almost a scoring
position
fly ball right field mookie bets and
three scoreless with tony gosselin
that's grounded out in the check swing
to open the game
he extends his hitting streak to seven
games on the first pitch of the third
but the offense has started to look more
like it should 2-0 on muncie oh yeah
he's using 55s pat again magic
magic
the machine
works again
and it is back to muncie who crushes his
33rd home run
are so many ways to help your teammates
letting them borrow your equipment
[Applause]
to muncie
muncie
to the seats
so albert's got 679 in his career and
then his bat has gotten three over the
last three days two for turner and now
one for muncie his second longest home
run of the year at 436 feet amazing
sures are saying i'm about to do that
i'm about to use that bat i'm gonna go
yard south runners at first and second
up comes will smith
[Music]
back to weaver
in the oh
ugly inning for the diamondbacks
continues he going to score four nothing
four scorers for godzilla goes back out
there van meter aboard on the walk ramos
hit the plate
hit sharply could be two there's one
there's two
four six three double play wipes them
clear
there's such a timing to the game and
you've got to make so many decisions and
trey turner knows take your time after
balls hit at you that hard on one hop
just take your time get the out
pull it out of your webbing too as that
one was hit so hard it almost went
through his glove
two odd single just the second hit of
the ball game against tony gonzalez andy
young will come up and pinch hitting the
nine spots so luke weaver's nice dog and
he gets him with a slider to finish off
five scoreless
tony godzilla with his best outing of
the season and there's one out
now turner coming in trey turner blasts
one into left center field indeed back
goes peralta to the wall it's gone
a home run trey turner his 22nd
and the dodgers lead it five to nothing
that was a no doubter off the bat of
trey turner what a beautiful swing
the tucker the extension
and it pretty much was no doubt
there have been some long fly balls
falling short but not this one
after johnson it is david price
who's been back and forth between the
rotation of the bullpen this year
settling back into the bullpen he's
happy to do so david has strike out and
he's fly to center and getting the ball
up in the air and off the ground he
sends this out to left center that's up
in the air and bellinger cuts it off
here comes rojos with the diamondbacks
first run and peralta hustles into
second with an rbi double dodgers up 5-1
here trill smith the lead off the six
for the dodgers
will smith doesn't break a lot of bats
take a look at this bat it's a lot of
chips out of the top the paint means
this one's had some wear and tear
i drive
left center field will smith parks it up
the pavilion about six or seven rows
long gone in a 6-1 lead on his 24th
that is gonna get put away
right there in the corner
with that swing and as hard as he hit it
he might have chipped some paint off of
it
this is not a broken bat swing that is
right on the barrel third home run of
the night for the dodgers they are 20
and one when they do that so it's first
and third here two on and two out four
cattell martay who has singled twice
tonight
drives it deep to center field cattell
martay it's gone
martay muscles up from that right side
once again and the diamondbacks are
right back in the ball game it's six to
four this is loaded nobody out here's
justin turner
who broke the game open on sunday with a
late home run two walks in a single to
load him up one ball two strikes on
justin turner who hits the high drive to
deep right field ramos backpedaling has
room
johnny deep enough to bring home the
runner from third and it's 7-4
sacrifice fly justin turner scoring max
muncie
smith homer does last time up in the
sixth first base sound of the rubber the
arizona right-handers 2-2
and will hits the ball to left field
going back on it is peralta tagging at
third is trey turner he will score
standing up back to back sacrifice flies
dodgers had two and they've doubled up
on arizona it's eight to four
so here's kenley janssen first outing
off of the paternity list
congratulations to kenny and his wife
gianni
sharply hit nice play by muncie springs
to his feet and feeds jackson
you can talk about the elite pitching
the dodgers are getting you could talk
about the offense waking up but these
gloves have been there the whole way boy
did we see an amazing play by corey
seeger lately we've seen justin turner
use the leather trey turner and now max
muncie over at first dodgers looking to
move to 40 games above 500. breaking
ball hot shot to third turner's got it
and the dodgers have punched their
ticket for the postseason
by winning their fifth in a row eight
for the final over the diamondbacks
tonight
you